tell me to Dream On hey uh Patrick
you're 22 years old I'm a regular guy
you know my parents divorced I don't
have a lot of money my dad's a cashier
at a 99 cent store I came from Iran I
lived at a refugee camp I'm a regular
guy there's nothing about me that I'm
coming with family money
any of this stuff something to drink hey
Patrick you Auto one day dot dot dot
some eat that what does that look like
well I mean I think you should do
whatever it is that you want to do and I
think you should be able to have a shot
to do that fairly so in other words I
don't think you should go bankrupt if
you get medical bills I don't think you
should you know have student loan debt
that's so extensive that you can't ever
pay it back and by the way you also can
file for bankruptcy on it because that's
the way that they wrote the laws
um I don't think people should be loaded
up to the brim with credit card debt
credit card debt is at a record high
right now I just read a stat the other
day 63 of Americans are living paycheck
to paycheck so really uh to sell you on
the dream I would honestly just point at
some of the Scandinavian countries and
say look they haven't eliminated
capitalism what they've done is they've
harnessed the good parts of capitalism
and mix it in with the good parts of
socialism so that they have you know an
intelligent hybrid where somebody who's
22 years old just getting out of college
can have a chance to do whatever they
want and make it it's okay so and I I
rebuttal because let's just say my uh
there's a classmate sitting there and
his dad's an executive at IBM hypothetic
and he's doing 600 000 a year and he
lives in a nice Community he says so
Kyle you know if my dad's told me if if
if these Scandinavian countries are so
great how come you're not moving there
and why is it that 40 million immigrants
choose to come to America and why don't
they choose to go to some of these
countries what do you tell that 22 year
old smart Ally well why I'm not going
there is because it's [ __ ] cold I'm
in Miami and I'm enjoying being in Miami
right now
um so if it was warm you would go is
what you're saying uh no because I love
my country I love America whenever I
criticize America it's coming from a
place of like I want to try to improve
it and make it better I don't think
everything about this country is bad or
wrong but I think that there are things
we can do to improve it and you know
there's a very famous quote from one of
the founding fathers descent is the
highest form of patriotism in the same
way that if you know God forbid you know
we saw one of our kids but hide a
dumpsters smoking crack behind in Arby's
we would be like you know what we're
gonna try to get them some help we're
going to try to get you in rehab we're
going to work on this we're going to fix
this it's that same mindset that you
apply to the country it's you know when
you look at some of the things going on
in this country you say this can't
continue I mean we have 45 000 Americans
that die every year because they don't
have access to basic health care that's
something we can fix and it's and you
know there's a lot of uh work put into
convincing people that it's just a law
of Nature and there's nothing we can do
about it no there's a lot we can do
about it okay so let's stay on that
let's hang on I want to sound this so I
want to go to the 22 year old and
selling the dream to this kid so going
back to it you know uh I don't know who
we had here on the podcast but uh
somebody recommends a restaurant to you
how do you and I judge a restaurant at
noon hey you know what I've never been
to Rifle before let's go there to eat
for lunch how do you and I judge a great
restaurant we've had a food taste how
the atmosphere is and then okay so the
atmosphere meaning what if if the place
is packed at noon and there's a hundred
people there and 20 people waiting to
get inside they're doing something right
okay if you and I go to a restaurant at
night and you're like there's a
restaurant in L.A rafi's place I go
there all the time if you go there on
Mother's Day it's a three hour wait okay
every day's busy it doesn't matter when
you go right right if anybody says
anything bad about the restaurant like
to say well you know my my thing is I
want to make this restaurant better
because I think this restaurant can do
if they put the chairs this way and it's
not fair the fact that the employees on
the bus boys and I'm like yeah dude but
but it's a good restaurant but it's
always it's not it's not a good
restaurant because you and I have an
opinion that's a good restaurant it's a
good restaurant because it's always
flipping packed right so if America was
and I know this is a random analogy I'm
using but if America was a restaurant
America is so packed and it's got a
waiting list that if it's so bad with
the existing ideas that it has why do so
many people still want to come here and
not anywhere else well there's a very
simple answer to that question which is
if you look at the places that a lot of
these people are fleeing they've been
absolutely obliterated they've been
destroyed so a lot of these countries
have been ravaged by the drug war
whether it's you know I think in
Honduras I read a fact a couple years
ago in Honduras there's more violence
than there was in Iraq at the peak of
the Iraq War so it's a pretty crazy
place I'm gonna try to flee that I don't
know about you I'm trying to flee that
I'm going to try to take care of my kids
um you know Mexico similar situation you
have these these drug cartels
effectively uh with help from our policy
we've made these Narco States you know
south of us yeah and so you have these
you know gangster states that are run by
drug cartels because what we've done is
we've of course we did the War on Drugs
we made it illegal what happens when you
make it illegal is it gets pushed under
ground to the black market that's how
you make the drug cartels more powerful
the same the same thing happened here
with prohibition when it came to uh the
mafia we made the mafia way more
powerful because we decided to make
alcohol illegal that's when they got
their most uh power and wealth and so a
similar thing happened with the drug war
what I would do is number one stop
intervening in those countries
militarily and that's you know a long
conversation we could have about the
history of the US intervening in that
area and number two let's end the drug
war so in other words just kind of take
our our boot off the neck of a lot of
these countries and make it so that
people want to stay there because
honestly I really believe this I think a
lot of the people who are coming here if
they felt like their home country was
safe and clean and okay then they
wouldn't want to come here I think in in
many cases it's a desperation Type move
but it's not just Honduras or Mexico
it's it's like okay you're uh half
Italian and you're half polish I wanna
is it polish or uh yeah so my my mom's
mom is from Italy basically and on my
dad's side it's more of a my last name
kalinski is a Polish last name but it's
I think it's a little more uh
you take your uh Italian right you take
Jews you take anything else you take if
America is so bad that some people sell
it as being so bad why do people keep
coming here what is what is so like okay
when we were in Iran we had options
people were going in to Spain so we're
going to Australia some were going to
this only because they couldn't make it
to America but everybody's number one on
the list was to come to America you know
what I'm saying it wasn't like they
wanted to go anywhere else again going
back that that is my biggest argument
where if America is so bad if capitalism
is so bad and abusive why do so many
people who are actually leaving an
abusive environment are willing to come
to a place that offers capitalism where
a person who has not got the last name
of Mitt Romney his last name is David my
parents haven't given me a penny last
time I got an allowance I was 14 years
old I'm not an allowance I don't even
know what allow is to be honest I'm not
even being sarcastic I don't know what
an allowance is right and so I come up
here I'm like dude I don't give a [ __ ]
if you give me allowance I'm just happy
to be here and I'm gonna bring my middle
eastern work ethic and I'm banking on
something's good going to happen to me I
don't have the money to go to school I
don't have the grace to go to school
maybe I'm going to go in the military
get my act together be away from some of
these guys that are doing drugs because
all my a lot of my friends were you know
ecstasy you know pot they were selling
they were done like I'm just got to get
away from this I go into the military
and then I come out I'm like okay I'm
gonna learn how to I was a bodybuilder
I'm going to learn how to sell this is
my way out so again for me it goes back
to the same thing if if America if
Socialism or social democracy is so
amazing why don't people go to those
countries first before they come here
well so I would say number one there
actually there is a refugee crisis in a
lot of those countries there are people
kind of pouring into those countries but
number two I think we're talking a
little bit past each other because I
wouldn't say America is bad of course I
win I'm here I love this country right
the question is I think it's just the
Wrong conversation I'm not a capitalism
guy you're not well social democracy
harnesses the best aspects of capitalism
so so there is an element maybe maybe
unpack the difference
so that you know there's socialism
there's Democratic socialism and there's
social democracy social democracy is a
hybrid of capitalism and socialism where
basically you you take the best aspects
of capitalism the best aspects of
socialism and you have this this mixed
system which you know in theory would
yield the best results and I just the
reason why I believe in that is because
I think there's a tremendous amount of
empirical evidence to those ends so like
for example they do this study every
couple years this Commonwealth fund
study where they look into the Health
Care Systems of basically you know a lot
of the developed countries 11 of the
developed countries and when they do
that we always rank the U.S ranks 11th
out of 11. so we're doing worst on that
front so
um now when it comes to the issue of
capitalism look I mean I could I can
make the argument for you here when you
look at for example the cars that came
out of the Soviet Union
they were abysmal they were you know
they were made by one government agency
there was no uh competition so you
didn't get a better product at a lower
price and that's that's what I'm trying
to avoid which is why I believe in
something like social democracy because
you can still have uh particularly when
it comes to consumer goods I think it's
good to have competition I think it's
good to try to get you know the best
price with the the best product and and
compete in fact I believe in uh and I'm
curious if you would agree with this uh
I think we really need to start doing
antitrust action again I think we should
do anti-monopoly stuff again because
when a business becomes a monopoly what
do you get higher prices worse product
and so you need to break them up just
like Teddy Roosevelt did to get it to
the point where you have more
competition you can harness the best
aspects of capitalism so when you talk
about that so I believe in that while at
the same time I also believe in taking
care of the basics so in other words
um they have like sectoral bargaining in
a lot of the Scandinavian countries that
means you set wages the union negotiates
with management and you set wages kind
of across an entire industry I think
that's a good idea because it helps
working people out more I believe in
like I said universal healthcare
Universal education or trade school you
could you should have your choice and I
think they do that in Germany they give
you an option you want to go to trade
school or you want to go to college I
just hate this notion that in this
country some people come out of college
and they're 80 000 in debt and they're
like well what the [ __ ] do I do now and
I can't even pay this back and then they
got to go take a job where they're way
overqualified to even take that job I
think that's [ __ ] up I just think
there shouldn't be such a thing as
medical debt or or school debt uh and I
don't think these ideas are all that
radical I think most people would agree
with this even people who would consider
themselves capitalists so let's go
through the school debt let's go through
the school debt so who who caused that
like meaning how did we get here because
40 years ago College wasn't that
expensive you know if you look at the
numbers of 40 years ago versus today I
think inflation CPI is 220 percent in
the last 40 years since 1970 or 1980s I
think it's 1970. and then uh cost of
college education has gone up 1200
percent CPI 220 percent inflation 1200
percent how do we get to a point where
college has become a business it's no
longer like what it once was started for
yeah well College was free or nearly
free uh in California and then Ronald
Reagan came in and took that away so it
really is a matter of priorities
um I don't I think this is something
that honestly should be fully
nationalized I think we should have a
fully nationalized education system
trade school system
um I think this is one of those areas
where we've kind of experimented with
the free market and the results have
been disastrous in the same way that I
think for-profit health insurance
companies are basically just a legalized
Mafia That's in between you and your
doctor where they take their cut and
they price gouge you that's not every
industry that would fall into that
category I think there are many
Industries where
um capitalism and and competition works
out for the better for people yeah um
this is just not one of those Industries
and I think the evidence bears that out
so okay so so
um nationalized college so I guess the
question goes back to the final if I got
a billion dollars and you have a choice
between a given a billion dollars to a
free enterprise okay let's give a
billion dollars to Elon let's give a
billion dollars to musk I'm sorry to
Bezos let's give a billion dollars to
whoever that's in the free market take
any of the top 200 guys that made it
from zero to there okay give billion
dollars to them versus giving a billion
dollars to the US government say here go
see what you can do with a billion
dollars who do you trust will do more
with that billion dollars well it
depends on the topic right so uh I would
give the money to the government when it
comes to Pharmaceuticals because a lot
of people don't know this but for the
past two decades there hasn't been a
single drug that hasn't been developed
with government grant money so basically
the government steps in gives money to
universities and says hey we need this
new drug which does X Y or Z and then
they create it and then you have the
pharmaceutical companies swoop in buy up
the patent rights and then sell it back
to everybody at a profit even though
they didn't fund the research and
development So my answer would be it's a
complicated question and it depends on
the the you know it depends what we're
talking about there are plenty of areas
where I'd say yeah give that money to an
entrepreneur no idea be more specific
give me an idea like I'm actually cured
I'm actually really you're a smart guy
you're a very well-read guy you have
strong opinions and this is your world
I'm actually curious so if I gave a
billion dollars to public versus you
know a private in what areas you think
so one was pharmaceutical Fair what else
would you think they would do good
versus they would do bad like it's
better to put on a free enterprise well
the other I actually just gave the
example uh before I think with uh like
cars uh the government should have no no
business
yeah of course no business in you know I
don't want the government building like
furniture or some [ __ ] that's something
that's squarely for technology for the
private sector Tech I think is a little
more complicated because a lot of the
products that we use today that we kind
of take for granted like stuff like
these phones a lot of that was
originally developed with funding from
NASA so in some ways the government
actually does Science and Technology
very well but to your point yeah there's
plenty of you know uh entrepreneurs and
and private investors who would probably
do it just as well if not better on some
topics so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here